all the sirens in the world weren't loud
enough to sound the alarm for what was
happening inside tender care living
center
last december within a week of its first
covet case
31 residents were infected another week
later
156 residents and staff were positive
and those numbers would keep careening
out of control
[Music]
james ha could only watch from the
outside praying his 83 year old father
fan kim ha would survive the storm
what are you thinking as you're watching
this on the news i'm thinking
you better be putting in protocols
to protect those who haven't been
infected
tender care did have a plan in place in
case there was an outbreak
it had been in writing since the spring
when the first wave proved how deadly
covet could be inside a long-term care
home
the plan was to use a vacant wing of the
fourth floor to isolate any residents
who were positive
toronto public health says it verified
it and according to the document
tendercare could set up the unit the
same day staff like this personal
support worker
whose identity we've agreed to protect
say they were briefed on the plan
at meetings they told us time and time
again in case of anything
the residents would be moved to the
fourth floor but when covert hit on
december
4th that plan wasn't put into play
and the crowded old home where nearly
all residents share a room
many with three in four people was
vulnerable
what they were doing and i was so upset
they were moving the residents from unit
to unit
it was a big and huge mistake by moving
the residents back and forth
so it kept spreading like that six days
into the outbreak
and a team from scarborough health
network came in to support tender care
pressing them to enact the plan an email
from the home to families the following
day
said we've agreed to move all residents
positive with coveted 19 to our fourth
floor
we have 20 vacant rooms but the fourth
floor
was never used everybody was like
stunned
because the residents weren't moving to
the fourth floor and what did they say
to you what was the answer
i think they weren't prepared they were
just talking but there was nothing being
done
the company contracted to manage tender
care extendicare
one of the largest owners and operators
of long-term care homes in canada
said staff were falling ill and they
didn't have the resources to open the
floor
it was now 12 days into the outbreak and
there were warnings
if this continued everyone could become
infected
toronto public health intervened
ordering the home to separate covet
positive and negative residents
but by this point a hundred and eighteen
residents
already had coveted i think it was way
too slow
so far james has father had not been
infected
toronto health i believe should have
acted
much more aggressively as soon as they
are aware of the outbreak
toronto public health says the next day
the home provided a new plan for
separating residents
and began implementing it right away but
two of the home's four doctors were sick
and staffing levels were plummeting a
call went out among a group of doctors
on social media
that tender care needed help dr kate
greenway
a family physician put her hand up when
i arrived on sunday
and i started seeing these people that
were very ill certainly what i was
ordering immediately was oxygen and
dexamethasone
and then at some point later in that
that shift you know one of the nurses
just said well we don't have any more
anywhere what oxygen they were out of
oxygen right
i sort of said back i don't i don't
understand like what
where do we get the oxygen and they said
well we have to order it from the oxygen
company but then they have to deliver it
and that takes quite a lot of time
so without oxygen and without
dexamethasone to open up those lungs
yeah no you're in trouble tendercare
says it tried to secure supplies
but the region was seeing a surge in
covet cases and resources were scarce
to green away the home felt frenetic
it was pretty shocking to me that it was
possible
to seem so unprepared for for an
outbreak greenway was able to get oxygen
and dexamethasone from scarborough
hospital
you personally made the call right he
didn't know who was insurance i did not
know
tendicare says its executive director
francis martus was in charge
until he too contracted covid we reached
him by phone
we're just trying to figure out why the
fourth floor wasn't used because
could you be willing to do an on-camera
interview with us
tender care says after martis was
infected directors from extendicare took
charge
but adds decisions on how to separate
positive and negative cases
were guided by toronto public health
management did tell staff that if they
felt sick they shouldn't come to work
and they were screened at the door but
at least one employee we spoke with said
she worked through her shift while her
fever grew because she had no sick days
left
tendercare says it offered unlimited
paid sick days for kovid
but multiple workers told global news
they knew nothing of this policy
if you don't get sick days you have no
sick days in the bank you won't get paid
management didn't say to you if you're
sick we'll still pay you to stay home
no they're not going to pay you to stay
home
on christmas day 22 days after its first
case tender care relinquished management
of its home
to north york general hospital dr kevin
katz is the hospital's director of
infection prevention and control
it was it was widespread and the
transmission was rampant at the time
that we stepped in right on christmas
day
stabilizing the home became the focus
for katz's team
and they recruited 50 doctors from
across the province
was tender care ready for the second
wave well clearly not
i believe every long-term care home was
asked to fill out a preparedness
survey and they were all told formally
that they were accountable for infection
prevention and control but
clearly they weren't ready to manage
what they experienced
this is the preparedness assessment
tender care filled out in august
months before the outbreak it ranked
itself 4 out of 5 near the top of the
scale for readiness
in every category including infection
prevention and control
stating audits are done monthly and
training is provided to all staff
but put to the test those on the ground
said
there were gaps i think it's clear
that the the issues when we went in
uh related to training and education
how they were using ppe environmental
cleaning it's a repeated theme
in all of these very very large
outbreaks ministry inspectors had been
flagging issues at tender care for years
including at the beginning of the
outbreak when they documented
widespread problems with infection
prevention and control
and improper use of ppe tendercare told
global news it takes swift action to fix
issues raised in ministry inspections
they should have just declared
this this disaster zone and moved in as
soon as their inspectors
sent in their report it was early
january
fully a month into the outbreak when
james ha
got the news he had been dreading my
worst nightmare came to reality when
i learned to the beginning of january
that he was infected
his father was transferred to hospital
where he would spend three weeks before
returning to tender care
a much more frail version of himself
covet had ravaged his body and coupled
with dementia
robbed him of his ability to swallow and
then
yesterday
sorry he had some food particles
that came into his lungs and he died he
died
basically of suffocation fan
kim ha isn't included in the staggering
death toll at tender care
but his son has little doubt had he not
contracted covid
he would still be here he would
absolutely still be with us today
[Music]
the owners of tender care during the
outbreak didn't respond or refused to do
an interview with us i'm trying to reach
john is he around the president john
doherty
i will give him the card and if he wants
to speak to you he will deferred our
questions to the management company
extendicare its ceo
michael guerrero we're trying to reach
dr grayer we have for quite some time
wouldn't come downstairs
to speak with us my husband's probably
on the phone
got it can i leave you my card in a
joint email response
tender care and extendicare said they
responded immediately
and through every available channel to
get the supports needed to the home
but the stress on the health system in
the region at the time
meant that delivery of supplies
additional staff and other support
was not immediate on february 1st
the outbreak at tender care living
center was declared over
81 people were dead all but five
residents in the home of just over 200
people
were infected and 105 staff
tested positive some continue to
experience symptoms today
other workers took cove at home to their
families infecting them as well
and among the unseen scars of covid the
trauma
of putting body after body into bag for
some workers to stay away
even longer it's essential that we
talk about what we saw because we want
to prevent this happening in any other
home
there is deep sorrow among those who
stepped foot inside tender care during
those
harrowing eight weeks and a growing
sense of frustration
that we should have done better there
are major gaps
very very serious gaps in the system
that are letting these people down
and some of us went in to try to fill
those gaps
this wasn't a gap that we could fill
there was a systemic failure
somewhere in the system that allowed it
to come to the levels
it had come to when we walked in